hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to sister location
custom night now we're gonna do weirdos
and this one doesn't actually seem all
that hard we only have the mini Rena and
the electro Bab and then yendo and
bonnet it's it's not even any active
threat it's only yendo that's the only
one that can actually kill you and then
a little bit just you got type lol or
click on the keypad either one doesn't
you just do the Duke and he's gone so
we're gonna go into this and we're gonna
smash through these next few ones
because it seems like they're just an
interesting combination as opposed to
anything that might actually be
challenging the only thing we gotta look
out for is electro mode cuz there's
nobody at the doors that's for damn sure
here we go Oh [ __ ] Wow ok yendo might
be a bit of a problem if he's gonna be
that big of a dick to me but other than
that not too terribly bad that's gonna
be weird if he endo doesn't go away on
the on the second flip up because if he
can't appear twice in a row that's kind
of a bit of a problem
point but on that not too terribly bad
it might be best actually to get in the
habit of double flipping the camera as
soon as it comes down because you never
know when he might not be there but then
again if he's not there then there was
no point doing that and you kind of just
wasted some resources oh well we'll
figure it out
yeah there's apparently I don't think
there's a power penalty for doing the
controlled shock so as soon as as soon
as it goes up there might be it might be
prudent just to shock right away just in
case there's something there cuz you
never know if he's not there then you
just move along the other one and hope
that it rolls over yeah this isn't too
bad this is easy it's really easy this
is like ridiculously easy come on okay
bye-bye
yeah I thought you were gonna give me a
challenge here I thought this is gonna
be difficult but a fair
i endo Bayou yeah it's like it's like
clock oh yeah no has a cool-down
okay that makes sense hey I had you go
away so it seems that yendo has a
cool-down and here comes the next batch
of power suckers so the power drain
comes at like predictable times because
I'm able to know in my head roughly when
there should be another one and it
always overlaps with an oxygen if you do
it at the right time so I'm wondering if
everything else can have a predictable
pattern too but I'm about to finish this
night with the most I've ever had
history of ever the only rogue element
is if yendo doesn't go away on the first
flippy flap but i think that he does go
away that's just him appearing again
which is entirely possible not taking
you with me go [ __ ] yourself
alright what else we got here I bet it's
bad oh don't look at me my caramel skin
is bad you better hide around the corner
don't get be mad no one's gonna save you
when I eat all of your faces then I'm
gonna go can't be anymore
anyway that was probably my most
cheerful song out of all that we got
topsail bottom shelf cupcake challenge
alrighty then
so the only interesting thing in this
one is that it combines funtime Freddy
and Belarus so there's two things that
you need to listen to if there's bitty
babban here then there'd be three things
that you need to listen to and that
makes it a bit more interesting cupcake
challenge also removes that yes so the
only time that you adapt three things to
listen to is actually on golden freddy
mode but either way we're gonna roll
through this so top shelf it is hello hi
I'm here now oh boy hi yes
not exactly a surprise okay okay getting
a rhythm out of it get your rhythm not
too bad this is easy this is manageable
because just determining on whether or
not still they're confirming on whether
or not the lure is actually getting
close or not which is gonna require
absolute silence on my part because I am
a flattering idiot hey doc gonna make it
yeah hell yeah I didn't name any big
bill
nobody did Bill is many many
[Music]
do-do-do-do-do da da do-do-do-do-do Here
Come a victory Here Come a victory here
come the victory better come my vision
1% loved I'm the best I did that even
with 3 / 3 3 50% I said words correctly
and stuff and things
how's this gonna Duvall well the Saints
so good
I fell better and I know what I'm doing
everybody side from me I can old friends
no one here to love me up just a burp
guy with no jerk what happened to me
weak meet you happy man Oh
[Music]
oh what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you won't die
die won't die you won't die now you
won't die you won't die die you won't
die die die die die I won't die oh oh oh
okay oh okay sure
goddamn that rocketed out of your body
like nobody's business so what does that
mean that's the interesting question
that I have what did that mean I mean I
understand the fundamental concept of
you won't die and therefore purple guy
was not just the combination of the two
of them purple guy is now the
resurrected evil version of the
scooped-out entity that was a nerd ah ah
that's [ __ ] weird um okay so if I had
to fully if I had to fully rationalize
what I just saw so purple guy is
literally empty inside because all of
the innards were scooped to make the way
for inert
so in that capacity purple guy is like
this soulless heartless completely empty
shell of a man who likely isn't a man
who somehow kept alive after they were
transformed by having entered inside of
them and then when it finally came time
for enter to leave after maybe an her
discovered that it wasn't working the
changes have been so severe and entered
promise that you wouldn't die came to
life in that something was left behind
not mechanical in terms of like
literally left behind and entered but
something a bit more I don't know
above that something horrible was left
behind and who you were in sister
location was changed forever and just
this hollow empty walking shell was left
behind and that's who purple guy was and
maybe that's Matt maybe that's why
purple guy constantly felt the need to
fill the empty void inside the hollow
shells of his animatronic friends
throughout the rest of five nights at
freddys that's just the thought but it's
an interesting thought so anyway so I
don't know if there's more to that but
Wow alright let's try the bottom shelf
should be just as easy all I'm gonna do
is have people on my face and beanie
band that's it that's literally it this
is so easy yeah this is so easy so easy
uh-huh thank you
okay do that uh-huh oh you didn't do
okay that's too bad for you
the only thing literally the only thing
that makes this particular one difficult
is the fact that I can't see the lol
keys behind my microphone I literally
have to guess what I'm nailing it every
time cuz I'm just uh no you're not
[Music]
you're not okay I don't know if there's
gonna be another good scene
none of those thing could nope okay so
that's the only cutscene that we got so
the only thing left on our list and that
was super easy is the cupcake challenge
and golden freddy mode and that would be
the easiest thing in the world how is
this very hard how is that hard that's
not hard at all it's easy you don't even
have yendo in there let's give it a go
just gotta listen for Valora
and fun had time at Red Deer but even
they're not running at maximum capacity
yeah this is definitely gonna be more
hectic not impossible but certainly
hectic okay we're not doing too terribly
we may not win on this one I will
actually move but on this one we're
pretty close we're sitting at 49% in
three am really not that bad for first
time on this one I just got to be better
about getting old [ __ ] got you're just
getting exactly what I was talking about
they're hitting the the power ones yeah
we're cutting it pretty close but we're
actually doing better than we just did
if we can keep up this pace we might be
able to make but it's gonna be just
barely if we do Oh [ __ ] what I got
your nose ah dammit it's okay I must
have must have forgot about him when I
was flipping the camera up and down okay
so that wasn't too bad I can do this let
me just go back in there and I know that
Scott himself has said that it's
actually literally impossible to be
golden freddy on 20 mode which I don't
know I don't know I honestly don't know
like how capable he hasn't beaten game I
would imagine he's pretty dang good
considering it
he made the game cut how long was that
up and I probably just [ __ ] myself oh
[ __ ] yeah that's why yeah that I
remember why I put up that door it was
to keep her out ah [ __ ] I got to stop
talking I could have beat that easy but
you know I was just trying to talk but
anyway I'll finish what I was gonna say
Scott himself has said that he has not
been able to beat 20 mode he has not
been able to beat golden freddy mode on
very hard and I'm imagining that he's
probably pretty good at the game
considering he made it but whether that
means it's impossible
is up in the air like who's to say we
don't know if he's the best player of
all time and I'm not claiming to be the
best five nights at freddys player but I
am pretty damn persistent so if I can't
beat it
then I don't know what I'm gonna do I'm
probably gonna know if I can't beat it
after a few hours of attempts but I
gotta get through this first so let me
just do this no talking and then I'll be
good to go
so I've noticed I just want to say real
quick the electro Babs are always going
to be an opposite always going to be in
the opposite corner that the funtime
Freddy's sorry of course it gets crazy
when I'm trying to talk about something
of course it is so he's always in the
opposite that's something to note mostly
for myself cover you guys unless you
guys want to pick up something from that
you can totally do
[Music]
doing good I think I'm gonna yell yeah
easy alright once I stop and OH
blabbering my big fat piehole
I suddenly realized all this skill
inside my soul and there's not gonna be
another not gonna be another crack at
the good old cutscene but alas the only
thing we have left to do is golden
Freddy oh it should be way up benefi
[ __ ] people have been saying that easy
is not so easy but doable normal is
pretty hard and then hard is the real
challenge here um people are saying that
very hard mode is impossible but I'm not
100% sure about that
who knows maybe assistant no one is
beating yet let me give it one go I'm
gonna just one old gander with all of my
skill intact I don't know how that's
gonna go
we shall see
hello no pusher I'm not well that was
yep sells pretty dang hard I kinda man
yendo makes that a problem but either
way that is gonna be a son of a [ __ ] to
attempt I'm gonna try though I'm not
sure if I'm gonna try you know to dive
in too hard and then go to very hard
what I'm pretty sure I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna try to hammer away it very hard
first and if I can do that or if I can't
do that then I'm going to go down too
hard but we shall see that it's for
another day and by day I mean literally
I'm gonna dedicate a full day to trying
this sack of [ __ ]
so either way thank you everybody so
much for watching and let me know what
you thought down the comments below and
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]